[Musique]
il a presque quotidienne régionale il
est télévision locale vous présente
le club des territoires
et avec nous pour ce club des
territoires Arnaud Bénédicte bonjour
Arnaud merci d'être là rédacteur de la
revue politique et parlementaire et le
constitutionnalisme Benjamin Morel
bonjour Benjamin comment ça va depuis
hier
j'ai dormi
et pour un club spécial consacré
évidemment sénatorial elles auront lieu
dimanche et Samia
de ça vient vous allez nous éclairer
dans quelques instants sur les engins du
mode de scrutin oui qui vote dans quel
département on fera un peu un mode
d'emploi de ces élections peu
particulière
[Musique]
et avant de voir les enjeux on va
regarder le dernier épisode de notre
série sur la campagne à travers les
départements pour ce dernier jour
direction Paris 12 sièges sont à pouvoir
à pourvoir si la gauche par une île à
droite elle part en ordre dispersé
Jérôme Rabier et Adrien
c'est assez rare pour être souligné
toute la majorité municipale d'Anne
Hidalgo par rassembler à Paris
socialiste écologiste et communiste
peuvent espérer passer de 7 à 8 sièges
sur les 12 places de sénateurs en jeu
mais pas question le crier trop fort le
rassemblement n'a pas qu'un objectif
arithmétique il a
aussi une brosse pour le PCF ou encore
Yannick Jadot pour les écologistes
feront à coup sûr leur entrée au Palais
du Luxembourg et eulv pourrait même
envoyer trois élus au Sénat si le
huitième siècle est conquis mais c'est
bien un combat commun qui est porté
c'est gagnant-gagnant le rassemblement
dans d'autres départements les Verts
vont soutenir des listes conduites par
des socialistes qui grâce à cela seront
élus donc l'objectif c'était vraiment de
faire progresser la gauche au Sénat
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle
écologiste passerait ainsi du Parlement
européen au Sénat pour y prolonger ses
combats j'ai travaillé 14 ans sur les
lois européennes notamment en matière
d'environnement je sais combien et vous
savez combien la France est en retard
moi je veux contribuer dans le cadre
législatif à faire en sorte que les lois
françaises soient au moins à la hauteur
des lois européennes si la gauche par
confiance c'est qu'en face la droite
parisienne perpétue la tradition de la
division au grand dam de Catherine Dumas
qui sortent et tête de liste officielle
des républicains qui a bien du mal à
l'expliquer aux grands électeurs
et oui elle est accompagnée en deuxième
position du ténor du barreau et mère du
16e arrondissement Francis spinner un
choix qui ne fait pas l'unanimité chez
les élus et les grands électeurs mais
pour elle il n'y a pas débat elle dirige
la seule liste digne de ce nom
en fait de mes concurrents comme vous
dites franchement je me pose des
questions je suis la seule à avoir des
élus sur sa liste Elvis trois sièges
pour sa liste mais elle est fortement
concurrencée notamment par Agnès
Séverine euro député président de la
Fédération LR parisienne qui n'a pas
apprécié que le 15e arrondissement dont
elle est élu soit mis de côté notre
liste de rassemblements et d'ouverture
soutenue d'ailleurs par le maire du 15e
Philippe Goujon et également Hervé Morin
qui est le président du parti centriste
permettra donc au 15e arrondissement le
plus peuplé de Paris d'être représenté
au Sénat elle est normalement assurée
d'obtenir assez de voies pour être élu
16 conseillers de Paris de droite ayant
soutenu sa candidature et malgré les
pressions à l'étaler au bout de sa
démarche
alors aujourd'hui c'est un moment clé de
la campagne sénatoriale puisqu'il s'agit
de faire valider donc par la préfecture
les documents de campagne alors là vous
voyez c'est la profession de foi et puis
le bulletin de vote un troisième
bulletin de votre sera à la disposition
des grands électeurs de droite Pierre
Charron élu depuis 2011 mais exclu de la
liste officielle ayant décidé de
repartir au combat ce jour-là il a
rendez-vous avec sa deuxième de liste
une novice en politique bonjour Pauline
très bien merci Pauline déroulette s'est
fait connaître pour son combat pour la
sécurité routière elle qui a perdu une
jambe renversée par une personne âgée
qui n'avait plus la capacité de conduire
à ses côtés Pierre Charon mène une
campagne médiatique et ira vu sur les
choix de sa famille politique on m'a
fait une
au-delà de sa seule famille politique je
pense que c'est important de s'adresser
aux 2881 grands électeurs pour leur dire
à chacun aussi parler à d'autres que
vous connaissez nous on dit personne
n'est propriétaire des voix ça c'est je
veux dire c'est 2180 hectares il vote
dans l'isoloir
2880 grands électeurs parisiens qui par
leur vote désignerons donc 12 élus la
capitale étant la circonscription
électorale avec le plus de représentants
au Palais du Luxembourg
et on va regarder l'ensemble des listes
candidates à Paris vous l'avez entendu
12 sièges sont à pourvoir c'est le
territoire qui compte le plus grand
nombre de sénateurs et je vous rappelle
que cette élection sénatoriale elle aura
lieu dimanche on va en parler tout au
long de ce club on commence par Paris
puisqu'on vient de voir sur portage
union à gauche division à droite on va
commencer par la droite la droite
parisienne qui décidemment n'arrive pas
à se sortir de ses divisions la droite
parisienne qui en effet n'arrive pas à
sortir de ses divisions et qui est très
très marquée aujourd'hui à la fois par
des dissidences qui peuvent être des
dissidences personnelles et par un
rapport qui est compliqué avec notamment
la majorité présidentielle et je dirais
que Paris ça plaide aujourd'hui pour
justement une forme de suspense dans ses
élections sénatoriales parce que vous
voyez que dans un territoire où on vote
à la proportionnelle en fait la plupart
des grands électeurs sont des super
délégués nommés par les conseils
municipaux etc et bien malgré tout on a
une forme aujourd'hui d'incertitude tout
bêtement parce qu'on ne sait pas
exactement pour qui voteront les grands
électeurs donc il y a des choses qui se
jouent il y a des combinaisons qui vont
pouvoir se qui font que notamment à
droite les choses restent relativement
imprévisibles n'ont pas tant sur le
nombre de sénateurs d'ailleurs que sur
leur identité à gauche mais on voit que
l'union entre guillemets comme dans tous
les modes de scrutin et bien à la
capacité de faire plus de sièges ce qui
va permettre notamment ELV d'augmenter
un peu son nombre de sénateurs ici à
Paris et donc on a encore une fois un
certain nombre de choses qui peut bouger
au Sénat on va revenir évidemment sur la
gauche peut-être un dernier mot sur la
droite Arnaud la droite parisienne avec
une liste soutenue par Rachida Dati
est-ce que c'est aussi les municipales
de Paris 2026 qui se joue
c'est peut-être un peu tôt pour le dire
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est une
droite archipel la droite parisienne
c'est une droite qui est orpheline d'un
leader depuis Manon de très nombreuses
années et qui n'en finit pas avec une
crise j'allais dire qui maintenant vient
de loin il à Paris on verra bien c'est
vrai que trois listes en effet ça divise
la part du gâteau forcément en
l'occurrence et on voit que les
divisions de la droite parisienne qui
sont très anciennes on n'arrive pas à
les résoudre et se scrutin sénatorial
est intéressant parce que tout
simplement illustre une fois de plus ce
phénomène alors est-ce que ce sont
uniquement des aventures personnelles
parce qu'il y a la liste officielle DLR
mais la liste de Pierre Charron Pierre
Charron c'est un très proche de Nicolas
Sarkozy donc qui est plutôt sur une
ligne de rapprochement avec la majorité
présidentielle c'est ça et c'est là où
on est fait les potences enfin les
prochaines municipales se jouent un
petit peu car quelle va être la
positionnement de la majorité
présidentielle et de LR fasse notamment
à Hidalgo ou à son successeur potentiel
donc là il y a malgré tout des jeux qui
qui se tendent et vous avez par ailleurs
une droite qui fonctionne énormément en
réseau à Paris et donc ces différents
réseaux vous situez le réseau Sarkozy
peuvent permettre d'activer des grands
électeurs au contraire de les désactiver
pour tel ou tel candidat ce qui fait que
même si après les municipales et bien
vous avez un paysage qui apparaît
relativement simple grand électeurs de
la majorité de la gauche de la droite en
réalité c'est un paysage beaucoup
beaucoup plus éclaté et dans le secret
d'isoloir il peut se passer bien des
choses on va parler de la gauche la
gauche qui part uni mais sans la France
insoumise oui certes mais la dynamique
est favorable à la gauche à Paris
d'abord parce que bon madame Hidalgo a
remporté alors dans les conditions que
l'on sait au moment de la crise
sanitaire l'élection municipale que la
gauche est unie et que en l'occurrence
elle dispose en effet d'une dynamique
qui lui permet en tout cas de
capitaliser mais on est déjà presque
j'allais dire à gauche aussi peut-être
dans l'après Hidalgo c'est la vraie
question qu'il faut se poser et donc là
aussi on voit que un certain nombre de
leaders commencent à se positionner et
là aussi des sénatoriales nous disent
quelque chose sur l'état des rapports de
force à gauche mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'ils ont fait ils ont
ils ont priorisé l'Union elle est fi est
à côté mais est-ce que le poids de LFI
est aujourd'hui suffisant pour d'une
certaine manière handicapée la Gauche à
Paris je ne le compare non c'est très
limité dans certains départements où ça
va se jouer à quelques dizaines de voix
les listes la fi peuvent éventuellement
faire basculer des sièges non pas en en
prenant un mais en en faisant perdre un
à la gauche ça c'est possible ce sera
pas le cas à Paris les grands vainqueurs
et je rejoins Arnaud là dessus ça va
être les Verts c'est à dire que sans
cette union les vers n'auraient
probablement ne feront probablement pas
autant de sièges que là ils ont feront a
priori ce qui montre que le fait que la
majorité des Hidalgo accepte et bien de
donner une plus grande place au verre le
fait que d'un point de vue national
cette alliance aujourd'hui apparaît
nécessaire et bien montre à la fois un
affaiblissement du parc socialiste dans
les territoires l'arrivée de repécologie
les Verts et la nécessité pour le PS de
gagner des à la fois contre la droite et
la majorité mais également contre la FI
et on va revenir à un nationalement sur
la France insoumise qui présente des
candidats partout on va en parler mais
juste pour finir sur Paris le grand
perdant ça pourrait être la majorité
présidentielle
le siège de monsieur barjoton est un
siège difficile à conserver il y a quand
même un grand gâchis du côté de la
majorité présidentielle à Paris un
gâchis qui est lié à l'échec des
élections municipales parce que
finalement quand on se reporte quelques
années en arrière et il y avait disons
une dynamique potentielle importante
pour la majorité
présidentielle à Paris qui a été gâché
suite un certain nombre d'événements sur
lesquels on ne reviendra pas mais qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas la
majorité présidentielle risque de perdre
ce poste de sénateur mais la réalité
c'est que ces élections sénatoriales
au-delà de Paris seront difficiles pour
la majorité présidentielle pour une
raison qui est structurée le mécanique
que l'on connaît tous c'est que il y a
une faiblesses du mariage territorial de
cette majorité et c'est l'un des sujets
d'ailleurs majeurs pour cette majorité
on va en parler on quitte Paris on va
parler de l'enjeu national de ces
élections sénatoriales mais d'abord
Samia puisqu'on est à 48 heures du
scrutin maintenant faut refaire un point
avec vous sur les enjeux de ce scrutin
oui ça se passe dimanche Oriane la
première précision importante c'est que
seule une partie des sièges de sénateur
est concernée par ces éléments puisque
le Sénat est renouvelé par moitié tous
les trois ans donc sur un total de 348
sénateurs seuls 170 sont renoués cette
année et ils seront élus pour 6 ans ce
qui veut dire qu'on ne vote pas dans
toute la France on vote en effet cette
année dans 45 circonscriptions ce sont
celles qui vont apparaître sur la carte
qui s'affiche à l'écran et vous pouvez
le voir il y a deux couleurs parce
qu'attention deuxième particularité au
sénatorial il y a deux types de scrutins
en fonction du nombre d'habitants les
départements les plus peuplés ce que
vous voyez en vert sur cette carte il
vote à la proportionnelle et les
départements les moins peuplés ce qui
n'existe que un ou deux sénateurs votent
au scrutin majoritaire et là les grands
électeurs votent donc pour une personne
et non pas pour une liste qui sont ces
grands électeurs justement et bien ce
sont essentiellement des élus n'ont pas
tous les Français qui votent ces
élections ces notoriales puisque c'est
une élection indirecte alors qui vote
donc ce sont des élus municipaux les
élus des départements et des régions et
puis les parlementaires mais en fait
l'essentiel se sont quand même les élus
municipaux qui représentent 95% des
grands électeurs ce qui fait que le
résultat des sénatoriales il dépend
beaucoup du résultat des dernières
municipales oui et vu les bons résultats
de la droite aux dernières élections
municipales de 2020 on peut déjà dire
qu'elle va rester majoritaire au Sénat
elle l'est déjà comme on va pouvoir le
voir sur un graphique le bleu domine
largement l'hémicycle il y aura bien sûr
quand même des évolutions sur les 8
groupes politiques qu'on peut voir à
l'écran certains vont gagner des sièges
de sénateurs d'autres vont en perdre
mais globalement les grands équilibres
ne devraient pas être bouleversées par
ces élections sénatoriales qui seront
certainement plus marqués par une forme
de stabilité merci Samia Benjamin il y a
quand même très peu de chance que la
majorité sénateurs
majoritaire qui a du suspense
vous pouvez pas mentir à noter les
spectateurs
non il y a malgré tout du suspense on va
peut-être avoir une petite montée de la
gauche notamment de la gauche or partie
socialiste ce qui peut être intéressant
du point de vue des recompositions au
sein de l'opposition on va peut-être
avoir une petite baisse de la droite
c'est à peu près ce que l'on attend
peut-être d'ailleurs plus du côté des
centrices que de LR et surtout on va
avoir des recompositions au centre vous
savez que vous avez un groupe
aujourd'hui leur des pays qui est un
groupe au Macron ce groupe il n'est pas
certain qu'il survivent à ses élections
en revanche les philippistes et bien eux
visent à former un groupe et donc on
pourrait avoir quelque chose qui se
recompose dans ces centres avec
peut-être et bien
quelques élus et il peut y avoir une
montée et ça va être intéressant à
observer du vote RN parmi les grands
électeurs si c'est le cas ça veut dire
que le phénomène de notabilisation
d'ancrage du RN et bien a plutôt
fonctionné et que la stratégie de la
cravate au niveau local et bien en un an
à pas mal payé et pour appuyer ce que
vous venez de dire sur le terrain en
reportage effectivement quand on suit
les sénateurs à la rencontre des maires
la plupart des élus qu'on rencontre nous
disent que cette année l'étiquette
politique des candidats qu'elle
rencontre effectivement compte moins que
d'habitude et pour avoir suivi certains
candidats du rassemblement national
effectivement c'est c'est vraiment là
dessus qu'il mise notamment dans le
Pas-de-Calais pour pour essayer de
décrocher un siège et du coup ça peut
créer des surprises Arnaud le fait que
c'est de savoir si le rassemblement
national sera en mesure de ramener des
sénateurs il y a eu de sénateurs par le
passé au Sénat
issus du Front national à l'époque
est-ce que le rassemblement national est
en mesure de ramener des sénateurs à mon
avis c'est pot également possible en
l'occurrence c'est-à-dire en effet vous
avez un certain nombre de départements
le Nord le Pas-de-Calais ça sera plus
difficile dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
parce que le mode de scrutin est
différent où il y a là des marges en
tout cas pour le rassemblement national
je rejoins ce que dit Benjamin
c'est-à-dire aussi le vote des ondes
rurales sera extrêmement important à
scruter parce que on sait que ce sont
des hommes ou le rassemblement national
fait des scores importants à la fois à
l'élection présidentielle et si aux
élections législatives et on va mesurer
en effet la capacité d'acculturation
politique des députés du rassemblement
national à leur territoire alors ce sont
pas les députés qui font quand même
l'élection sénatoriale loin de là mais
en tout cas ça peut être un indicateur
qui est important ensuite il y a quand
même d'autres mais ça veut dire juste
parce que Arnaud on a beaucoup parlé
avec vous avec Benjamin du fait qu'il y
avait un peu de vote il y a le vote des
élections nationales où on voit que la
majorité présidentielle et le RN effort
et puis il y a le vote des élections
locales ou là c'est toujours les
républicains et le PS qui restent fort
sur les territoires est-ce que là du
coup le RN peut réussir sur un vote qui
reste quand même un vote local à gagner
des sièges
2022 c'est l'élection de 88 ou 89
députés du rassemblement national à
l'Assemblée nationale donc ça ça peut
avoir un impact sur l'implantation
locale même si c'est une élection
nationale ça peut avoir un impact
d'autant plus que force est de constater
que la stratégie de banalisation de
normalisation de dédiabolisation d'Iron
certains du rassemblement national
depuis finalement la parlementarisation
du rassemblement national a plutôt joué
si l'on regarde les sondages en faveur
de Marine Le Pen alors est-ce que ça
aura un impact sur le vote notamment des
élus dans les zones rurales c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudra en effet
scruter de près il y a un autre sujet
quand même juste sur lequel je voudrais
revenir à gauche
c'est le parti communiste on va y
revenir sur la gauche
sur le sur le RN ça veut dire que même
s'il ne réussissent pas à avoir un
groupe ils peuvent quand même grignoter
sur leur implantation locale et
continuer à tisser leur toile en vue des
échéances à venir exactement c'est
l'objectif en réalité ça va être un
révélateur encore une fois ça permettra
probablement pas au RN d’avoir un groupe
mais ça va être très révélateur
c'est pas beaucoup mais si vous avez une
montée il faut voir que le mode de
scrutin sénatorial et bien tant à
invisibiliser à la fois les les parties
les plus polarisées ça donne un avantage
on dit souvent le Sénat est
structurellement à droite non le
sénestre naturellement au centre droit
son mode de scrutin le pouce vers le
centre de l'autre côté tant que vous
n'avez pas gagné les élections pendant
20 ans il est très difficile en réalité
de faire quelque chose au Sénat donc
pour le RN c'est très compliqué mais on
peut avoir une montée du vote des grands
électeurs parce que admettons que vous
soyez une grande lectrice plutôt de
droite dans un une circonscription ou un
département qui a majoritairement vos
TRN les points qui faisaient que
jadisent vous n'auriez jamais pu voter
RN aux élections sénatoriales commencent
à disparaître le fait que vos électeurs
pourraient vous sanctionner c'est plus
une question en réalité ils ont
majoritairement voté pour rassemblement
national et puis par ailleurs vous aviez
peut-être peur que ce sénateur RN que
vous pourriez lire et bien ne soit pas
capable d'incarner quelque chose de
défendre le gouvernement le département
au Sénat or là la stratégie de la
cravate le fait que les députés et ben
localement en règle générale pour le RN
fasse le job ils vont à la fois à l'ail
il sert à la main de Monsieur le Préfet
il présente relativement bien c'est
toute la stratégie de la cravate et bien
montre que vous pouvez avoir une
représentation qui est une
représentation correcte donc quelle
mesure ça peut faire sauter les tabous
dans quelle mesure ça peut orienter des
votes qui jusqu'à présent était
inimaginable pour ses élus bah c'est
vraiment l'un des enjeux parce que si
c'est le cas ça veut dire que demain et
ben pourquoi pas après tout et bien
tendre la main au RN sur des élections
locales et donc à partir de là formé
pour le RN je dirais une une base locale
qui demain peut se développer et ils
n'ont pas gagné que des députés depuis
les dernières sénatorielles ils ont
aussi gagné des conseillers municipaux
et encore une fois pour citer l'exemple
du Pas-de-Calais la prise de de bruit et
la Buissière où ils ont beaucoup d'élus
peu peut-être aussi même si c'est pas
suffisant pour faire un siège faire une
différence et ça combiné à la volatilité
du vote des élus municipaux
effectivement il y a certains
départements où le le rassemblement
national peut espérer davantage des
prochains siège
ah non on va parler de la gauche
sans que vous aviez envie de parler de
la gauche avant de parler avant de
parler du Parti communiste un mot sur la
France insoumise parce que il y a eu des
accords à gauche entre le Parti
socialiste le Parti communiste les Verts
mais sans la France insoumise du coup la
France insoumise a décidé de présenter
des candidats dans tous les départements
au risque de faire perdre des sièges à
la gauche
la France insoumise texte et on voit un
message à ses partenaires de la nupesse
c'est-à-dire sa capacité à un moment
donné de nuisances c'est-à-dire sa
capacité à empêcher le succès d'un
certain nombre de candidats de gauche
ils instaure depuis le début de toute
façon de cette aventure de ce cartel
electoral qui est la nupesse c'est un
rapport de force indéniable à
l'intérieur de la famille politique
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas un
scrutin qui dort il fait qu'il aurait
forcément favorable parce que
territorialement la France insoumise est
faible en l'occurrence c'est un parti
d'élection nationale la France insoumise
d'élection présidentielle d'élections
législatives pas forcément d'élections
européennes parce qu'il faut quand même
aussi avoir en tête que derrière les
sénatoriales il y a tout ce qui se passe
en vue des européennes et où on voit que
pour l'instant la gauche c'est plutôt et
en train de partir en ordre en ordre
dispersé
la France insoumise n'est pas en mesure
vous les probablement d'avoir un gain de
siège mais par contre est en mesure de
faire perdre un certain nombre de
candidats sur le terrain
oui il peut y avoir en effet quelques
pertes liées encore une fois quand ça se
joue à quelques dizaines de voix même si
votre liste ou votre candidat est bien
ne pèse pas grand chose d'un point de
vue local c'est quelques mois elles
peuvent vous manquer donc là en effet il
peut y avoir quelques défaites à gauche
liées à ces disques et je rejoins Arnaud
l'objectif de la France insoumise c'est
pas d'avoir un groupe ni même un
sénateur ils savent très bien que ça va
être très très compliqué l'objectif
c'est de rentrer dans un rapport de
force notamment à pour ce qui compte
pour eux c'est à dire les élections
européennes et l'idée d'avoir une liste
ce qui permettrait de ne pas rebattre si
jamais il y a une liste unique les liens
de pouvoir et les rapports de force au
sein de la nuque après il y a des gros
enjeux à gauche tout de même en termes
notamment de variétés juste là sur la
nuque ça va laisser des traces le fait
que la France insoumise présente des
candidats ou des listes concurrentes à
celle de la gauche alors je crois que ça
rentre dans un climat global traité de
Jacques Doriot Fabien Roussel n'est pas
la meilleure façon de maintenir les
liens au sein de la nuque le fait
évidemment de rentrer en opposition sur
la liste sur les Européennes et pas la
meilleure façon de de maintenir une île
à nuque évidemment les élections
statoriales je dirais c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau en tout cas c'est une
façon de pour la France insoumise de
faire monter la pression sur ces sur ses
partenaires sachant très bien que
là-dessus ils n'auront pas gain de cause
après il va y avoir des enjeux je dirais
postérieur pour la nuque notamment la
l'élection à la présidence du groupe
socialiste on a aujourd'hui un Patrick
Kanner qui n'est pas vraiment le plus
mais
socialistes et donc ce faisant si jamais
il y a un changement de tête parce qu'un
Patrick cannaire peut être affaibli par
les élections dans le Nord ou parce que
vous avez une transformation au sein du
groupe et que le groupe virent plus
product ça peut tout de même changer les
choses dans les rapports de force au
Sénat si jamais évidemment la France
insoumise rentre en lutte Larv contre
ses partenaires et bien cette possible
transition risque d'être plus compliqué
alors pour la précision dans le Nord
effectivement Patrick canard et candidat
à sa réélection il y a 16 listes qui
sont en jeu enfin qui se présentent pour
11 postes et donc quand même 6 listes de
gauche il a une sénatrice sortante face
à lui une liste LFI qui se présente
effectivement face à lui représentée par
Hugo bernalicis et effectivement les
parfois les sièges vont se jouer à
quelques voix donc il est sa réélection
est assurée mais il n'est pas en
position de force dans le Nord mais ça a
toujours été une alchimie complexe une
élection sénatoriale c'est vrai
aujourd'hui mais ça l'était par le passé
parce que on voit bien que sur une
élection sénatoriale vous n'avez pas que
des enjeux nationaux loin de là et que
les équilibres aussi locaux rentrent en
compte dans la fabrication du sénateur
c'est ça c'est un point très important
on est dans des logiques territoriales
qui ont leur propre j'allais dire au
fonctionnement et qui font que les
stratégies finalement nationales sur le
plan des élections sénatoriales jouent
assez peu ensuite sur l'orientation et
le choix des grands électeurs parce que
il y a d'autres enjeux qui sont encore
une fois des enjeux locaux qui viennent
d'une certaine manière
quelque part expliquer le vote des
grands électeurs
[Musique]
le groupe le plus en difficulté les
groupes les plus en difficulté c'est
plus ils sont plutôt au centre c'est
plutôt le RPI donc le groupe Renaissance
le groupe Renaissance qui risque de
perdre dimanche soir si vous voulez le
groupe Renaissance paye encore une fois
ce que l'on disait tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire la faiblesse de
l'implantation territoriale de la
majorité présidentielle notamment à
travers en marche aujourd'hui
Renaissance les élections municipales
n'ont pas été bonne en plus pour la
majorité présidentielle et notamment
pour en marche en 2020 donc
mécaniquement ça a un impact en plus en
plus en plus il faut quand même aussi ne
pas oublier que les rapports entre le
local et le National ne sont pas des
rapports extrêmement fluides et donc ça
peut aussi jouer si vous voulez il peut
y avoir un vote sanction de la part d'un
certain nombre de grands électeurs
vis-à-vis des candidats de la majorité
présidentielle et il risque de payer
également une attitude prédatrice entre
guillemets des autres groupes parce que
si vous avez un groupe Philippe piste
demain ça va se fonder probablement sur
les indépendants Claude malure et
exetera ça peut aller manger un peu sur
une oncentrice mais également évidemment
sur les macronistes et donc il va être
assez intéressant recevoir entre un pôle
horizon qui pourrait gagner Renaissance
qui pourrait perdre exactement c'est à
dire que on pourra avoir une
restructuration assez intéressante de la
majorité présidentielle au Sénat qui est
déjà très très réduite entre d'un côté
un groupe horizon et de l'autre un
groupe plus macroniste Wars la
disparition de ce groupe et voir
également ceux qui pour ensuite aller à
l'Union centriste etc il faut voir que
ce pôle centriste il est extrêmement
fluide il est extrêmement peu structuré
et qu'évidemment des moments où vous
avez un élément qui bouge bah c'est un
peu je dirais le château commence
dimanche soir en fait ce qui va se jouer
c'est l'après la composition des groupes
et les alliances éventuels alors l'après
va être extrêmement intéressant il faut
se donner rendez-vous pour voir un petit
peu exactement
ce qui va se passer la composition des
groupes les présidents de groupe parce
qu'on a plusieurs présidents de groupe
qui s'en vont parler du CRCE ben il y a
une assassin de la suite qui va prendre
la tête du groupe socialiste est-ce que
ça continue avec Patrick Kanner ou
est-ce que ça change vous avez le
sénateur Reiki qui part également à la
tête donc vous voyez que saxo reconfle
qu'un groupe charnière le RDSE vous avez
une partie de sénateurs qui pensent
plutôt à droite c'est le plus vieux
groupe de la de la République il date du
début du 20e siècle et donc la majorité
est à gauche comment est-ce que tout ça
se recompose en même temps vous avez
beaucoup de Macron compatible et puis
ensuite évidemment il y a l'élection au
plateau et là aussi le suspense est
profond et un soutenable
surprise énorme Gérard Larcher doit être
conduit un dernier
en revanche il y a gros suspense sur la
composition des groupes benjamin est là
on en parlera il y a quand même un
suspense pour savoir qui va se présenter
au plateau est-ce qu'il y aura par
exemple une candidature centriste qui
incarnerait la candidature de gauche
candidature de gauche Unis différente
candidatures de gauche donc ça signifie
ça sera quand même relativement
signifiant pour arriver et évaluer la
cohérence de la majorité satariale et la
cohérence de la cohérence de
l'opposition vous voyez qu'il y a du
suspense va durer on continue à en
parler du coup la semaine prochaine on
je vous donnerai les rendez-vous
évidemment ce sera à suivre ce week-end
sur Public Sénat d'abord on regarde ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
et ça vient elle a une de la presse
régionale c'est la visite du pape à
Marseille oui abemousse papa un titre La
Provence où l'on peut lire la fierté de
la cité phocéenne d'accueillir le pape
François qui incarne je cite
l'indignation en action migrants
car le Pape a prévenu il ne vient pas en
visite d'État en France mais à Marseille
pour dénoncer le drame du naufrage des
exilés il va d'ailleurs en rencontrer
plusieurs pour les Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace François c'est le pape des
migrants on peut y lire l'espoir que
suscite sa venue chez ceux qui
travaillent auprès des migrants à
Marseille ce jouet hier le match de la
Coupe du monde de rugby entre la France
et la Namibie oui formidable bleu se
réjouissent ce matin la Dépêche du Midi
après l'écrasante victoire de la France
96 à zéro face à la Namibie c'est la
plus large victoire de leur histoire un
score historique mais une frayeur pour
Dupont s'inquiète le progrès hier soir
le capitaine des Bleus a dû sortir du
terrain après un choc violent à la
mâchoire il y a une suspicion de
fractures si sa blessure venait à se
confirmer ce serait un énorme coup dur
pour l'équipe de France qui perdrait son
maître à jouer redoute le journal en
Auvergne la montagne a l'air sur
l'explosion des demandes d'aide
alimentaire oui le caritatif est sous
pression prévient le journal qui propose
un focus sur la situation dans le
Puy-de-Dôme dans ce département les
Restos du Coeur servent en moyenne 38
000 repas de plus par semaine par
rapport à l'an dernier sous l'effet de
l'inflation évidemment les associations
ont du mal à suivre
osent des prix du carburant pour les
véhicules de collecte best des récoltes
d'un vendus la maison coûte plus cher à
faire tourner à contre une salarié du
Secours populaire et surtout les
associations cherchent des bénévoles il
en faudrait deux fois plus au niveau
national alerte les Restos du coeur on
termine une servi de presse avec une
idée de sortie week-end
de Nantes des chiens géants se balade
dans la ville jusqu'à dimanche ce sont
les géants de la compagnie de théâtre
royal de Luxe c'est un spectacle en
plein air dans les rues de la ville
alors rassurez-vous un ça ne soupe pas
des chiens qui mordent ce sont deux
chiens en papier mâchés qui font tout de
même jusqu'à près de 3 mètres de haut
voilà des sorties Benjamin on y va vous
êtes un peu occupés
Arnaud nouveau numéro le savant le
politique et le peuple l'enjeu du siècle
tout à fait alors on va on devrait
l'avoir politique le peuple l'enjeu du
siècle oui il nous a semblé Capri la
crise sanitaire il était intéressant de
réinterroger la relation de l'expertise
et de la prise de décision et donc c'est
l'objet de ce numéro avec des
contributions d'universités de
chercheurs de politique et de différents
responsables voilà c'est-à-dire la rue
politique et parlementaire merci
beaucoup Arnaud merci Benjamin d'avoir
été avec nous
[Musique]